they are playing and laughing but like
the Shadows on this pitch the trauma is
never far
away this ship is home to survivors of
last year's catastrophic earthquakes in
southern turkey a floating Hotel it
features rooms a dining hall and
entertainment
facilities social workers offer lessons
to some of the residents still
recovering from their ordeal for to
5-year-old gel is scared of entering a
building after the earthquake destroyed
her home her brother didn't make it but
she survived spending two days trapped
under the wreckage of a six-story
building luckily we have the sea and we
are living on a ship we built a small
world here we are a family yes the
government will give us new apartments
but I can't afford that amount of money
that's why I don't have any plans almost
1,200 people live aboard this four-story
ship most of them women and children
some of them men have work while others
especially the elderly stay
aboard meal times are an opportunity to
socialize and take comfort in one
another it's it was a great experience
for all of us to to witness their
improving wellbeing the school term
ended two weeks ago leaving children
with free time to
play I go to the park with my friends
we're having a good time but I miss my
mom's cooking and eventually they have
something to look forward to this
amusement park near es scander Port was
complete a submerge by the tsunami
triggered by the earthquakes a year ago
after repairs were made the park has
reopened to entertain visitors giving
many here hope that life is at last
returning to normal despite the enormity
of the distraction in tury's southern
city of hatai Cam alaz isander in
tur make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz